most of us first came to know Robin
Williams as a friendly visitor from
planet ork who drank with his finger and
made us laugh with his rapier wit motion
picture audiences have come to think of
him as an actor from whom to expect the
unexpected one moment he's a whimsical
Popeye the next a lost but hopeful
Soviet defector in Moscow on the Hudson
but tonight he's our co-host so please
help us welcome Robin Williams
ah look at these sequins everywhere go
crazy
who ordered the shrimp cocktail hello my
name is robin Leach welcome once again
to lifestyles of the rich and nervous my
voice is louder than a bull elephant in
heat please join with me now look out
there and see tiny pools appear EA
everywhere five no there's a billion
people watching tonight a billion people
that's more than mrs. Marcos pins and
maybe a week we don't know this so well
a billion people you think that
somewhere in China right now people
huddle around the TV going quick Bing LA
Irving Thalberg award we can't miss
there
this mr. job how you doing mr. a mr.
Houston you're right on top of job see
there it is
ah where are six nominated film features
basically so Vesta Stallone as the
Prince of Denmark
a brief clip from that right now to be
or what Thank You civility like to thank
Smith & Wesson thank you for those of
you keeping track me to those of you
keeping track there's only four more
Awards till Jack Valenti so get ready
he's back there
Jack boom boom boom and he's waiting for
a baby and he's not and ready to go it's
the second half of the show Nancy wake
Ron up I'm awake here we go
special part of the show our next
presenters a man was named to reckon
with the music business last year he
decided to give the motion picture
business a try as a producer of one of
the oscar-nominated the color purple
there's reason to believe he's here to
stay and there's a little sign backstage
saying leave your agent at the door this
man is really carrying in a very very
wonderful man won't you please welcome
mr. Quincy Jones
there has always been music even in the
beginning though we call them silent
movies there was really no silence it
was always music and since 1951 there
has always been Alex North tonight we
honor him for his achievements in the
composition of music for motion pictures
from a streetcar named desire until this
year's Prizzi's honor in all he's been
honored with 15 Academy Award
nominations during this incredible
career and so it is with great pleasure
that I present this special Oscar of a
lifetime of achievement as a composer of
motion picture scores to alex north
this one time I I will accept the
applause sound effects and not complain
but in any case I never dreamed of
receiving such a wonderful honor during
my lifetime and I think this is a nicest
and most pleasant way of getting the
Oscar I'm deeply moved appreciative and
grateful to the Academy and especially
those members of the music branch who
have been supportive all these years
since I have always believed that cinema
is a great communicator I am that much
more thankful for the unique experience
and satisfaction of having been able to
work in this medium it also offered the
added inspiration of collaborating with
some of the greatest authors and
playwrights and directors of this
century some here tonight but the time
doesn't allow me to recognize in
composing music for film I attempt to
achieve the following goals to meet the
demands and needs of the story conflict
and the interrelationship of the
characters involved and also hopefully
contributing my own personal comment I
would like to make a humble plea to all
of us involved in the movies and that is
to encourage and convey hope humor
compassion and adventure and love as
opposed to despair synthetic theatrics
and blatant bloody violence
and
and sex sex sex by all means indeed but
with a bit of mystery a touch of charm
and elegance and lots of imagination
thank you
he's really lousy seats yeah you can see
everything Oh a special thanks to Roger
Ebert and Gene Siskel in the balcony
thank you very much
our fourth nominated film is Prizzi's
honor it's the story of a hitman and
falls in love how you doing jack a
hitman who falls in love with a hit
woman the result being a hit damn film